morning John okay that's a weird word by
which I mean okay
okay means like fine good satisfactory
approved none of those words you can
have Kaizen there aren't any words that
are just capital letters this isn't
normal and yet okay is possibly the most
spoken word on the planet not because we
say it a lot in the US which we do but
also because we say it a lot everywhere
so many other languages have been like
yeah actually that one that one's good
we'll take that for Mandarin to Hebrew
to Flemish to Russian to Indian to
Portuguese okay isn't okay it's a common
affirmative word what does okay even me
it's like you want to approve of
something but not a lot finally we have
a word for it is good without all the
good tied up in it like if I fall down
you say are you okay
what you're really asking is is there
something wrong it's like an acceptance
without any values or perspective or
opinions laid on top of it and I want
that I can just be okay and that's okay
where did it actually come from though
allow me to introduce you to the only
wikipedia page that is a list of
potential etymologies for a word and
it's very long me it comes from oh i
this like scottish oh yes or from the
greek phrase hola kala meaning all good
maybe but etymologists and historians
have set it on three prime theories look
into the most settled upon one last but
let's start with a west african origin
that's brought to the US by slave 1784
verified use of the word k rather than
okay is a transcription of something a
slave said in north carolina and this
may come from a common west african
phrase okie or walk' depending on the
language that's basically an affirmative
or a back channel a back channel is what
linguists call that thing that you do
where you make a noise or you say a
phrase or a word it just to let somebody
know that you understood what they said
and among the many uses for the word
okay remains back channel like you're on
the phone and you're like okay uh-huh
yep mmhmm okay like that second the
Choctaw word okay which maybe was also
somewhat similar and other Native
American languages and from what I can
tell this is not particularly easy to
translate but probably it means
something to the effect of it is so and
also apparently sometimes used as a
back-channel weirdly enough the definite
thing that we do know is when it entered
into the popular lexicon of average
Americans as the letter O and the letter
K in the late 1830s there was this weird
fad for comically misspelling things in
newspapers I don't know and then you
would take those common mistakes and
create acronyms from them like another
example of a similar word was o w which
was for alright later they had oil
correct
o kay how this like all of the other
weird comical misspelling acronyms would
have been completely forgotten if not
for martin van buren the Democratic
Party decided to like take this weird
okay meme and apply it to Martin Van
Buren whose name sounded to Dutch I
guess ah he was from Kinderhook New York
and they called him old Kinderhook but
that probably also wouldn't have stuck
around if people hadn't been looking for
ways to save characters on telegrams
because you paid by the letter and then
okay continue to trundle down the
decades until we got to where we are now
for me the amazing thing about this word
is how normal and everyday it is despite
the fact that it is very weird and
unusual and we never notice that and it
sort of exists in the background as part
of the fabric of culture not as
something that we immediately identify
as something that we're confused and
amazed by but it is confusing and
amazing and I guess that's okay John
I'll see you on Tuesday